[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
guten abend zusammen sportliches später
zusammengefasst mit katja stresow
die schockierenden bilder mutmaßlicher
gräueltaten bestimmen nach wie vor die
kriegs debatten hier ist unser überblick
was geschah in butscher russische
soldaten sollen hunderte zivilisten
getötet haben
präsident wilinski spricht von
völkermord die russische seite von einem
erfundenen angriff
was geht noch an sanktionen nach den
möglichen kriegsverbrechen weist berlin
russische diplomaten aus und prüft
weitere maßnahmen
jetzt kommt es darauf an die
erderwärmung lässt sich nur einigermaßen
begrenzen wenn die welt in den nächsten
drei jahren radikal umsteuert warnt der
klimarat
schon jetzt markieren die erschütternden
bilder aus butter von mutmaßlich
hingerichteten ukraine eine neue stufe
in diesem krieg der westen wirft
russland kriegsverbrechen vor moskau
wies dies als inszenierung zurück
sollten sich die vorwürfe bewahrheiten
dürfte der druck noch härtere sanktionen
zu verhängen weiter steigen dazu gleich
mehr zunächst aber der blick in den
großraum kiew aus mehreren orten haben
sich russische soldaten inzwischen
zurückgezogen vergangenen mittwoch
sollen sie butter verlassen haben das
sagt die regierung in moskau butscher
liegt 35 kilometer nordwestlich der
hauptstadt kiew und hatte vor dem krieg
rund 27.000 einwohner
unsere kollegin katrin eigendorf konnte
sich heute vor ort selbst ein bild
machen
auf der box einer straße in butter sieht
es fast noch so aus als seien die
russischen soldaten gerade erst
abgezogen die leichen der menschen die
hier lagen haben sie inzwischen geborgen
es sind bilder die nur schwer erträglich
sind das innenministerium hat
journalistinnen aus aller welt
eingeladen lasst zu dokumentieren und
präsident selensky ist persönlich nach
untergekommen es ist ihm anzumerken wie
nah es ihm geht wenn er schildert wie
hier frauen vergewaltigt familien
hingerichtet wurden das land müsse
kämpfen aber gleichzeitig verhandlungen
führen
ich bin überzeugt dass wir auf dem
territorium der ukraine frieden
erreichen die ukraine kann nicht im
krieg leben denn wir sind im europa des
21 jahrhunderts
in zwar verkehrs bussen die sonst in den
vorstädten fahren bringt das ukrainische
innenministerium
journalistinnen zu den orten aus denen
die russische armee vertrieben wurde
überall auf der straße ausgebrannte
autos von zivilisten zerstörte russische
panzer im dorf macht tisch in zeigt uns
der berater des innenministers eine
familie die nach seiner überzeugung von
russischen soldaten getötet wurde dieser
abschaum hat eine ganze familie
gefoltert geprügelt und ermordet sie
werden dafür zur verantwortung gezogen
werden wir finden alle die diese
schreckliche tat begangen haben
präsident selensky bezeichnet butscher
als ein symbol für den völkermord
russlands an den ukrainern die welt soll
das sehen und gleichzeitig wollen die
ukraine genau dokumentieren vielleicht
wird über butscher eines tages vor einem
internationalen gerichtshof verhandelt
werden
wir sind jetzt mit katrin eigendorf in
butter und axel sturm in moskau
verbunden zunächst zu dir kathrin
beklemmend was du in einer reportage
schildert das was wir gerade gesehen
haben es stellen sich jetzt viele fragen
wie werden diese mutmaßlichen
hinrichtungen aufgearbeitet
es ist für die ukrainische regierung
unglaublich wichtig hier wirklich ganz
klar und dezidierten nachzuweisen was
passiert ist warum das ist in seinem
ausmaß so grauenvoll und unvorstellbar
dass man dem wirklich nur eine exakte
und gute aufarbeitung entgegensetzen
kann auch um der russischen propaganda
entgegenzuwirken
ich muss selber sagen als journalistin
habe ich selten so grausame bilder
gesehen wir uns heute vorgeführt wurden
die haben wir alle in unserem film auch
gar nicht zeigen können wir haben tote
gesehen die ganz klar spuren von folter
trugen wir haben eine familie gesehen
die hingerichtet wurde die am boden lag
so was führt man normalerweise nicht
journalisten vor das ist schon in seiner
art und weise auch sehr einzigartig was
die ukrainische regierung hier macht um
auch zu dokumentieren was hier passiert
um die welt immer wieder darauf
aufmerksam zu machen dass es sich hier
aus ihrer perspektive um einen
völkermord handelt das sind auch
fühlende schilderung wir wollen jetzt
auf die russische perspektive blicken
axel sturm in moskau wie ist die haltung
des kreml
die haltung des kremls sehr eindeutig
man weist jegliche verantwortung weit
von sich und zwar kategorisch
pressesprecher ps kopf kommentierte
heute die ereignisse vor ort würden
seiner meinung nach nicht mit den
schilderungen der ukrainischen seite
korrespondieren sie müssten dringend
überprüft werden es dürften keine
voreiligen schlüsse gezogen werden und
außenminister lavrov ging noch ein
kleines stück weiter und sprach sogar
von einer inszenierung die dazu gemacht
worden sei um dem ansehen russlands zu
schaden das verteidigungsministerium
selbst hatte sich gestern abend schon zu
wort gemeldet und berichtet in der zeit
in der russische truppen vor ort gewesen
seien sei kein einziger mensch zu
schaden gekommen
dann dank an euch beiden danke axel
sturm nach moskau und katrin eigendorf
nach kutcher
in anderen teilen der ukraine hielten
die kämpfe an die städte nikolajew und
odessa im süden des landes meldeten neue
russische raketen angriffe in odessa
bekämpften die feuerwehren bereits den
zweiten tag die brände in treibstoff
lagern und einer raffinerie die am
vortag getroffen worden waren in
mariupol scheiterte erneut der versuch
die bevölkerung mit bussen aus der
eingeschlossenen stadt zu holen 90
prozent der infrastruktur seien nach
angaben des bürgermeisters inzwischen
zerstört
die mutmaßlichen verbrechen von butscher
bei heute live dazu ein gespräch mit
human rights watch empfehlen wir gleich
ab halb acht auf unseren social media
kanälen und in der zdf- heute- app und
dort also in unserer app finden sie auch
sechs szenarien wie der ukraine krieg zu
ende gehen könnte und eine einschätzung
welches davon wie wahrscheinlich ist
die schreckensbilder von butscher haben
eine ziemlich große wucht entwickelt der
westen ist jetzt fest entschlossen
härtere sanktionen gegen russland auf
den weg zu bringen obwohl noch in dieser
woche gegen den von vielen geforderten
sofortigen öl und gas lieferstopp gibt
es in berlin allerdings weiter
vorbehalte mehr von thomas reichert die
schrecken von butscher erhöhen in berlin
den druck auf ein energie in barkow
gegen russland jeden tag überweisen die
eu-staaten über 700 millionen euro für
öl und gas hat putin fans sofortiges
ende aber soll deutschland noch zu
abhängig von russland sagt robert habeck
und das bauen wir jetzt alles zurück und
drehen es um das heißt ja dass wir mit
jedem tag daran arbeiten die
voraussetzungen und die schritte hin zu
einem embargo zu schaffen habe kündigt
an bis zum sommer russische öl importe
zu halbieren auf kohle komplett zu
verzichten das aber bleibt schwierig die
antwort der havag gibt es aus meiner
sicht unentschieden er sagt wir machen
weiter und wir erwarten dass wir einen
ersatz haben aber wir können nicht
jahrelang warten bis lieferungen aus
katar hier ankommen dann ist dieser
krieg längst vorbei währenddessen das
auswärtige amt als reaktion auf die
grünen von butscher die ausweisung von
40 russischen diplomaten mutmaßlichen
agenten angeordnet ihre arbeit schreibt
aus ministerin baerbock ist eine
bedrohung für diejenigen die bei uns
schutz suchen dies werden wir nicht
weiter dulden das haben wir den
botschafter russlands heute nachmittag
mitgeteilt
am abend noch ein einschnitt bei gazprom
germania der deutschen tochter des
russischen energiekonzerns übernimmt
vorübergehend treuhänderisch die
bundesnetzagentur
gazprom hatte den deutschen ableger
gerade ausverkauft an wen blieb unklar
ein risiko für die energieversorgung in
deutschland
die bundesregierung tut das notwendige
um die versorgungssicherheit in
deutschland zu gewährleisten
dazu zählt auch dass wir energie
infrastrukturen in deutschland nicht
willkürlichen entscheidungen des tramp
des kremls aussetzen der weichen in
berlin und brüssel ein fünftes
sanktionspaket gegen russland ohne ein
energie embargo aber mit weiteren
einschränkungen gegen putin unterstützt
den handel und finanzgeschäfte
ja wir müssen noch mal in berlin
erfahren bei theo koll also c/o berlin
zeigt klare kante wir haben es gerade
gehört eine große zahl russischer
diplomaten wird ausgewiesen wie es das
einzuschätzen genauso als klare kante
einerseits wird dass putin keine
schlaflose nacht bescheren das jetzt 40
russische diplomaten ausgewiesen werden
andererseits hat es wohl noch nie einen
größeren rauswurf russischer diplomaten
gegeben und man darf getrost davon
ausgehen dass es sich dabei um spione
handelt und die ausweisung gleich von 40
ist zu sagen jedenfalls kenner ein
empfindlicher schlag für die gesamte
spionage abteilung der russischen
botschaft hier die außenministerin hatte
es ausdrücklich auch damit begründet
dass diese botschaftsangehörigen ja
hierzulande jeden tag gegen den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
gearbeitet hätten und zusätzlich eine
bedrohung für diejenigen sein die hier
bei uns schutz vor dem krieg suchen es
ist in der diplomatischen sprache
jedenfalls eine klare reaktion auf das
grauen in butter
auch wenn es im vergleich zu einem gas
embargo und natürlich dann doch eher
symbolpolitik bleibt und damit zu
rechnen ist es russland im gegenzug die
gleiche zahl an deutschen diplomaten
ausweisen wird und die damit deutlich
kleinere deutsche botschaft in moskau
dann stärker geschwächt wird als
umgekehrt danke für die einschätzung
theo koll nach berlin und wir bleiben
mehr oder weniger beim thema
bundespräsident steinmeier übt
selbstkritik und träumt erstmals fehler
in seiner russland politik ein sein
festhalten am pipeline projekt nord
stream zwei sei eindeutig falsch gewesen
man habe an brücken festgehalten an die
russland nicht mehr geglaubt habe und
vor denen die partner deutschlands
gewarnt hätten so steinmeier
um sich möglichst schnell von russischer
energie unabhängig zu machen und um die
eigenen klimaziele einzuhalten macht die
regierung bei der windenergie tempo
umwelt und wirtschaftsministerium haben
sich auf eckpunkte für einen
naturverträglichen ausbau an land
geeinigt geplant sind bundesweit
einheitliche standards zum schutz von
vögeln
windkraftanlagen sind generell auch in
landschaftsschutzgebieten
erlaubt die bundesländer werden
verpflichtet zwei prozent ihrer fläche
bereitzustellen
genehmigungsverfahren sollen so
rechtssicher beschleunigt werden
ja und es stellt sich die frage wie
lässt sich die klimakrise abwenden drei
jahre bleiben uns noch die emissionen
endlich zu senken und eine lebenswerte
erde zu erhalten das sagt der
weltklimarat im ersten teil seines
aktuellen berichtes warnte das un
gremium schon bis zum jahr 2030 könnte
die erde um 1,5 grad erwärmen deutlich
früher als erwartet
im zweiten teil wurden die folgen
benannt hitze armut und hunger im
aktuellen und letzten teil geht es jetzt
um lösungsansätze mehr erfahren wir von
marco
co2 einfach so aus der luft holen diese
anlage in island kann es und speichert
tausende tonnen tief im boden ein
kleiner baustein im kampf gegen die
erderwärmung allein erreicht bei weitem
nicht aus denn auch in den letzten
jahrzehnten stieg der ausstoß von
treibhausgasen
kontinuierlich an wird nicht deutlich
mehr getan geht es auch in zukunft
weiter nach oben und die folgen von mehr
als vier grad erderwärmung wären
katastrophal um das 1,5 grad limit von
paris zu erreichen muss bis 2025 die
trendwende bei den
treibhausgasemissionen kommen sie
müssten schnell und drastisch sinken
die botschaft ist die emission jetzt
wirklich zu senken global und zwar um
die 45 prozent bis 2030 co2 muss wir
müssen netto null co2-emissionen um die
mitte des jahrhunderts bekommen und das
erfordert viel politischen willen es
erfordert sehr viel
investitionen der bericht sieht dabei
auch lichtblicke wind und solarenergie
werden immer günstiger und immer besser
es gibt lichtblicke insofern dass wir
gerade bei der technologieentwicklung
gesehen haben dass bestimmte
technologien sich besser entwickelt
haben als wir das erwartet hätten noch
vor 10 oder 20 jahren da es gibt mut
dass wenn man
in solche technologien reingeht
tatsächlich dynamiken besser sein können
als wir sie erwarten und auch das hilft
wenn moore wieder hergestellt werden
speichern sie enorm viel treibhausgas im
torfboden natürlicher klimaschutz in
denen die bundesregierung in den
kommenden jahren milliarden investieren
will
das kommt jetzt vergleichsweise
überraschend die isolation pflicht bei
einer corona infektion fällt weg vom
ersten mai an sollen infizierte nur noch
freiwillig in isolation gehen und sich
nach fünf tagen frei testen können das
hat gesundheitsminister lauterbach
angekündigt das robert koch institut
meldet 41.100 929 corona neuinfektionen
binnen eines tages
26.300 72 weniger als vor einer woche 23
todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben tage
incident sinkt weiter auf 1400 24,6
jetzt nach ungarn wo sich viktor orban
feiern lässt für den deutlichsten
wahlsieg seiner partei seit dem ende des
kommunismus beziehungsweise einer partei
selbst ein bemerkenswert breites
oppositionsbündnis von links bis rechts
konnte den 3 um von orbáns fidesz partei
nicht verhindern jetzt steht ein ganz
starker mann vor seiner fünften amtszeit
als ministerpräsident und die eu vor
weiteren konflikten wolf christian
ulrich
budapest am tag nach urbans triumph das
ganze land in den farben seiner
fidesz-partei so zeigt es die zeitung
sieht so aus als hätten nur wenige leute
veränderungen gewollt
ich hätte mich gefreut wenn jemand
anderes gewinn
viktor orban triumphiert an diesem
wahlabend bekommt dem parlament wieder
zwei drittel der sitze ungarn ungarn
offen seine anhänger
das ist ein gewaltiger sieht das wird
man heute bis zum mond hören und in
brüssel ganz sicher
kampfansage eines mannes der sein
autokratisches machtsystem mit dem geld
europäischer steuerzahler speist die eu
politiker fordern schon länger wegen
mängeln bei der rechtsstaatlichkeit
gelder für ungarn zu sperren alle neuen
straßen neue internetleitung neue
schulen werden zu 90 prozent von der eu
mitfinanziert wenn dieses geld plötzlich
fehlt dann glaube ich werde druck auch
der ungarin und ungarn auf die regierung
von orban plötzlich sehr groß scharfe
kritik an den umständen der wahl kam
heute von osze wahlbeobachter die
ungleiche berichterstattung in ungarn
und das fehlen von debatten zwischen den
spitzenkandidaten hinderte die wähler
daran eine informierte entscheidung zu
treffen
so sieht es auch der geschlagene
spitzenkandidat der opposition
nach zwölf jahren gehirnwäsche kann
orban jede wahl in diesem land gewinnen
indes konnte an seiner seite standen am
abend nur zwei weitere oppositionschefs
die anderen vier blieben einfach weg so
zerfiel die vereinte opposition am abend
ihre niederlage
auch in ungarns nachbarland serbien ist
am wochenende gewählt worden klarer
sieger der präsidenten- und
parlamentswahl sind staatspräsident
aleksander vucic und seine partei vucic
gilt als gemäßigter nationalist und kann
nun ohne stichwahl seine zweite amtszeit
antreten er möchte sein land in die eu
für pflegt aber gleichzeitig gute
beziehung zu wladimir putin die
opposition beklagt unregelmäßigkeiten
bei der gestrigen wahl
und hier gehts jetzt sportlich mit katja
striesow weiter und wir beginnen diesen
sportlichen montag mit der fußball
bundesliga borussia mönchengladbach
hätte gestern den dritten sieg
nacheinander klar machen können
stattdessen muss das team von adi hütter
froh sein über den einen punkt der es am
ende geworden ist gladbach spielt 1 1
gegen mainz und einer stand dabei ganz
klar im mittelpunkt
anerkennung von allen seiten für yann
sommer gladbachs torhüter gestern mit
geradezu unglaublichen reflexen der
schweizer rettet seinem team gegen in
der zweiten hälfte überlegene mainzer
einen überaus schmeichelhaften punkt
dabei hat mönchengladbach stark begonnen
verdiente führung durch embryo in der 33
minute nach der pause aber baut gladbach
mal wieder bedenklich ab dass es für
mainz nur noch zum 1 1 ausgleich durch
ohne sieg reicht liegt einzig und allein
an yann sommer der
sc freiburg hat nun doch einspruch gegen
die wertung des spiels gegen den fc
bayern münchen eingelegt die bayern
hatten samstag nach einem wechselfehler
16 sekunden lang mit 12 statt elf
spielern auf dem platz gestanden und das
spiel mit 4 zu 1 gewonnen jetzt muss das
dfb sportgericht entscheiden und noch
zum tennis laura siegemund hat mit ihrer
russischen partnerin vera zvonareva den
doppel wettbewerb des wta turniers von
miami gewonnen im einzel der männer
triumphierte ein 18 jähriger sein name
carlos reygadas aus spanien ja besser
curacon chronisch kopf herz und so das
lebensmotto von carlos alters dass sie
uns ein großvater vererbt hat gegen
caspar ett aus norwegen demonstrierte
der 18 jährige einmal mehr seinen
bedingten siegeswillen
in zwei sätzen gewann er in miami sein
erstes masters turnier und schraubte
seine jahresbilanz auf 18 siege in 20
matches sein vorbild rafael nadal
twitter zur glückwünsche und sogar könig
felipe gratulierte alcaraz per telefon
schönes motto das ist so in banken katja
so keine ohrfeige wie bei den oscars die
grammys sind in las vegas nicht nur
skandalfrei sondern auch ziemlich
politisch über die bühne gegangen beim
wichtigsten musikpreis wurde prominent
an die opfer des ukraine krieges
erinnert präsident see lenski schickte
eine videobotschaft
für lifte dort open bekam bruno mars mit
seiner band sonic die auszeichnung für
den song des jahres
mit elf nominierungen ins rennen
gegangen war jean bart ist der soul
musiker räumte insgesamt fünf grammys ab
sehr bewegt so kleine korrektur noch zum
schluss unserer reporter kollegin katrin
eigendorf war für unsere live schalte
vorhin in kiew und nicht wie ich gesagt
habe in butter sorry dafür so leider die
ganze woche wind und regen mehr weiß
gleich katja horneffer einordnende
informationen wieder um 21 uhr 45 mit
christian sievers im heute journal das
gesamte heute 19 team bedankt sich fürs
interesse wünscht noch einen angenehmen
abend und möchte sie morgen gerne wieder
sehen bis dann
[Musik]
guten abend der schnee vom wochenende
ist schon fast wieder passe allerdings
heute nacht kann es hier noch leicht
schneien dann aber wird es deutlich
regnerischer windiger und milder von
westen am donnerstag kommt sogar ein
richtiges sturmtief zu uns heute nacht
also fällt noch etwas schnee regen in
den östlichen und südlichen
mittelgebirgen sonst regnet es häufig
ganz im norden und ganz im süden bleibt
es wohl trocken es kann auch noch mal
glatt sein vor allen dingen in den
mittelgebirgen da sinken die
temperaturen auf plus 1 bis minus 1 grad
sonst bleibt die nacht bei 7 bis 3 grad
milder und morgen liegen die
temperaturen zwischen sechs grad in der
oberpfalz und 12 grad am niederrhein und
besonders über der mitte deutschlands
regnet es morgen kräftig am anfang an
hier in den östlichen und südlichen
mittelgebirgen auch noch ein bisschen
schnee regen dabei sein ganz anders
sieht es im nordosten aus da zeigt sich
häufiger die sonne der wind kommt aus
westlichen richtungen am mittwoch wird
es dann vor allen dingen in der
nordhälfte kräftig regnen am donnerstag
überquert deutschland ein sturmtief bei
temperaturen von acht bis 15 grad und am
freitag droht im südwesten intensiver
dauerregen guten abend